diese woche kommt limbo ins kino der
sieht am anfang ein bisschen aus wie ein
spielfilm version von bad banks
[Musik]
das ganze wird aber anders als bad banks
und ziemlicher krimi eigentlich der da
konstruiert wird also wir haben die
junge anna die in compliance bei einer
bank arbeitet das selber eine ganz große
moralist in denkt sie zumindest von sich
selbst und ihr fallen der
ungereimtheiten auf und sie springt am
ende ihres arbeitstages noch schnell ein
taxi mit ihrem chef um das zu erzählen
und dann erst kann hier dieser abend so
ein bisschen vor sich hin wie sie
vielleicht zu ihnen bin ich auf dem
sprung muss ich also wohl auf montag zu
trösten
munter könnte es zu spät sein das
spannende an dem ganzen ist dass diese
jungen filmemacher sich eine technik
ausgesucht haben die ein bisschen
herausforderung ist also das heißt sie
haben 90 minuten ohne schnitt gedreht
haben wir in letzter zeit häufiger
gehabt also dass wir haben vielleicht
erinnert man sich noch an victoria der
letzte der ins kino kam war 19 17
prozent ist ein kriegsfilm der sah aus
als wäre er ohne schnitt gedreht
allerdings hat man daher heutzutage mit
digitaler technik sehr sehr viele
möglichkeiten das im studio danach in
der postproduktion nachzubearbeiten und
da das ganze so aussehen zu lassen
das alles musste hier live sozusagen
perform werden also das heißt man hat
sich wirklich ein ablauf ausdenken
müssen das ist ja die große
herausforderung beim drehen ohne schnitt
das man sowas ähnliches inszenieren muss
ein theaterstück also das heißt es gibt
keine keinen zweiten tag es gibt keine
wiederholung wenn jemand sich verhaspelt
hat wenn irgend jemanden fehler macht in
dem ablauf muss das halt irgendwie
ausgeglichen werden vom rest
was glauben sie eigentlich will sie so
[Musik]
funktioniert das hier ist ja die große
frage wenn man sich sowas ambitioniertes
vornimmt noch dazu als abschlussprojekt
im gegensatz zu solchen film wie
victoria wo man ziemlich nah an einer
person dranbleibt ist hier die
herausforderung dass wir nicht nur eine
hauptperson haben sondern dass mehrere
personen sich am ende an einem ort
treffen sollen und dass man irgendwie
hinkriegen muss wenn wir nur eine kamera
haben und nicht schneiden und nicht
irgendwie verschiedene handlungsstränge
miteinander parallel setzen können wie
macht man das um das elegance
hinzukriegen
es gibt dafür eine lösung die es aber
nicht ganz so elegant wie man sie sich
hätte vorstellen können also wer wir
unterbrechen die kontinuität so ein
bisschen an 12 stellen wo wir
irgendwelche figuren folgen die dann gar
nicht mehr vorkommen nur damit wir jetzt
den übergang so zusammen schaffen von
der einen zur nächsten
das ist so ein bisschen und elegant
gelöst man finde ich weil weil man
dadurch eben die zeit absitzen sich
fragt ok wo kommen wir jetzt etwas
passiert jetzt und plötzlich ist man bei
der nächsten figuren die andere
verschwindet einfach danke schön
wissen sie die oberen verstecken
wie kann ich das mit meinen
dienstleistungen auf dauer nicht
durchkommen werden das zweite wasser
genutzt hat um irgendwie das ganze
vorwärts zu bringen weil wir natürlich
wenn wir so etwas aufbauen und
verschiedene personen zusammen bringen
wollen dann ist halt eine autofahrt
dabei wenn wir länger halt mit dem auto
durch die stadt fahren da passiert da
nicht so wirklich normalerweise würde
man das schneiden oder parallel
irgendwas setzen was passiert oder
verschiedene ausschnitte noch auf offene
gespräch nehmen oder sowas
da wird dann probiert viel mit musik zu
arbeiten also das heißt wir probieren
die spannung rein zu bringen indem dann
plötzlich da
trommeln und geigen und das ganze
orchester darüber gelegt wird also warum
finance compliance
mein job ist es dafür zu sorgen dass
kriminelle schlupflöcher gestopft werden
dass weder gleichheit und fairness
herrschen kann das korrupte marode alte
system einreisen herausragend bei den
schauspielern und man braucht ja sehr
sehr gute dafür wenn man sagt ihr spielt
jetzt 90 minuten durch gibt euch meinen
höhe ist martin semmelrogge da ist diese
immobilien ideal für ein wettbüro
ich könnte dich und die organisation
geld waschen gerade jetzt wo die zwei
leben hoch gegangen sind
der spiel zum kleinen hannover hat ganz
furchtbar kitschig alliance zum teil
also wirklich so völlig übertrieben aber
man nimmt dem sofort ab das ist diese
type die er spielt gibt und diesen
diesen typen in dem in diesem
siebzigerjahre leder jackett wasser da
immer noch trägt in diesem illegalen
boxer mio dass das den sofort gibt und
dass der und wie so ein typ halt ist der
genau das tut was er was an diesen film
machen muss ich war doch immer loyal dir
gehen wettbüros gehört wurden
ins kino sollten alle die sich anschauen
wollen ob deutsches kino noch irgendwas
anderes kann also dieses so schwaiger
nummern und alle die sagen
tatort ist mir ein bisschen zu
langweilig ich will ich will und was in
dem in seinem krimi format sehen was ein
bisschen was ein bisschen spannender ist
also das heißt wir haben alle die ein
bisschen ein bisschen experimentieren
wollen aber aber schon auf eine
klassische erzählung wert legen können
sind hier eigentlich ganz gut
unterhalten
[Musik]
dann lasst uns weg